ласкаво просимо назад до «Квантових обчислень на практиці» — я Олівія Лан, і сьогоднішній третій епізод буде присвячений
експерименту qaoa у масштабі utility. Якщо ти з нами від самого початку, ти бачив, як ми розбирали
квантове залізо IBM, фреймворк шаблонів Qiskit і найновіші техніки мітигації помилок,
які дослідники та розробники використовують для масштабування квантових circuit. Ми вважали, що дуже важливо надати вам весь цей
контекст і показати напрямок, у якому ми рухаємося, але тепер немає жодної причини чекати довше, щоб побачити всю цю інформацію в
дії. Отже, перед початком кілька речей, які варто мати на увазі: усе буде слідувати фреймворку шаблонів
Qiskit, тому ми пройдемо ці кроки по порядку: перший — відображення задачі, другий — оптимізація circuit, третій —
виконання з Primitives і четвертий — постобробка або аналіз результатів. Ми почнемо з досить невеликого прикладу,
щоб ти міг якнайкраще зрозуміти ці кроки та їхнє призначення, а потім розглянемо дуже схожий, але набагато
більший приклад, щоб показати, як можна масштабувати задачу до рівня 100 qubit. Я надам тобі всі
інструменти, щоб ти міг після цієї лекції самостійно розв'язати цю задачу. Наостанок — це не буде
покроковим розбором коду: як би ми не намагалися, із плином часу код старіє й стає застарілим, тому якщо ти
дивишся це відео через рік після виходу, я не хочу, щоб ти зациклювався на синтаксисі, який може трохи змінитися з часом. Натомість це буде
детальне обговорення логіки та постановки задачі. Однак є навчальний notebook, який доповнює це
відео й прикріплений в описі нижче. Відстежувати код або звертатися до нього після перегляду
цього уроку та запускати його самостійно — це найкращий можливий досвід навчання. Отже, як короткий нагадувач:
не всі обчислювальні задачі підходять для квантових обчислень. Прості задачі та нескладні розрахунки не потребують
цієї технології, оскільки класичні комп'ютери вже чудово справляються з ними. Станом на 2024 рік
три галузі, щодо яких ми найбільш оптимістичні у дослідженнях, це: моделювання природи, обробка даних зі складною
структурою і, нарешті, оптимізація. Задачі оптимізації — одні з найскладніших обчислювальних
задач для ефективного розв'язання. У задачі оптимізації ти шукаєш найбільше або найменше можливе значення
для заданої функції вартості. Однак для багатьох задач, що нас цікавлять, знайти цей екстремум стає експоненційно складнішим
зі збільшенням розміру задачі. Ось чому це так важко обчислити. Наприклад, уяви, наскільки
складно обчислити оптимальні маршрути польотів або маршрути доставки по всій країні. У цьому уроці ми
розглянемо конкретну задачу оптимізації під назвою Max cut, яку ми розв'яжемо за допомогою квантового
алгоритму — квантового апроксимаційного алгоритму оптимізації, або qaoa. То що таке задача Max cut? Задача
максимального розрізу — це тип задачі комбінаторної оптимізації, визначеної на графі, де мета полягає в тому, щоб
розбити вершини графа на дві підмножини таким чином, щоб кількість ребер між двома підмножинами була
максимальною. Наприклад, у цьому графі кожен вузол з'єднаний ось так, а Max cut показаний цією хвилястою
лінією, яка ділить вузли на фіолетову групу та сіру групу. Щоб перетнути найбільшу
кількість ребер, потрібно розрізати п'ять ребер. Для цього графа, оскільки граф такий маленький,
неважко спробувати кілька можливих розрізів на папері або навіть подумки і з'ясувати, що п'ять — найкращий можливий
варіант. Але уяви, якщо кількість вузлів подвоїться, а потім потроїться — це швидко стає неможливим зробити вручну,
а після певної кількості це стає настільки складним, що навіть суперкомп'ютери не можуть надійно повернути найкращу відповідь. Це пояснюється тим, що
максимальна кількість розрізів зростає експоненційно зі збільшенням кількості вузлів. Хоча це може здатися трохи абстрактним,
існує багато реальних задач, які можна звести до задачі Max cut, наприклад виявлення шахрайства у фінансах, кластеризація графів,
проектування мереж та проектування VLSI, а також аналіз соціальних мереж.
Приклад із соціальними мережами особливо легко зрозуміти: скажімо, ти хочеш знайти групу людей, які мають якнайбільше
зв'язків з іншими людьми на платформі соціальних мереж, щоб ідентифікувати активних користувачів або людей, які мають
найбільший вплив у групі. Компанії насправді досить часто намагаються це робити. Ще один момент: Max cut часто є
підпрограмою більшої задачі, тому він може не визначати саму програму, але використовуватися під капотом — це
набагато поширеніше, ніж ти можеш наївно думати. Тепер час розпочинати.
Перший крок — створити наш граф. Це можна зробити, імпортувавши пакет Python під назвою rustworks. Визнач,
скільки вузлів ти будеш використовувати, задавши число n, потім додай свої вузли до графа G. Тобі також потрібно буде
додати ребра. Зробимо це вручну, просто перелічивши їх у масиві, ось так, де ти вказуєш останнє
число, яке задає вагу ребра, тобто наскільки сильно з'єднані два вказані вузли. Тут ми просто
використаємо вагу один для всіх, але пізніше тобі може сподобатися пограти з вагами і подивитися, як змінюється розв'язок.
Щоб зрозуміти, що означає вага в цьому контексті, повернімося до нашого прикладу з соціальними мережами. Можна уявити,
що ця вага відображає, наскільки впливовою одна людина може бути для іншої. Твій зв'язок із чоловіком/дружиною або родичем,
наприклад, мабуть, матиме вищу вагу, ніж із кимось, хто просто знайомий. Тепер намалюй свій граф —
прикріплений навчальний матеріал покаже тобі правильний синтаксис. Спочатку, перш ніж розглядати, як
відобразити цю задачу на квантовий circuit, давай створимо контекст того, як задача Max cut стає задачею оптимізації.
Для початку розглянемо мінімізацію функції f(x), де вхід x — це
n-вимірний вектор, компоненти якого відповідають кожному вузлу графа. Надалі ми будемо називати цю функцію
нашою функцією вартості. Потім нам потрібно обмежити кожну з цих компонент значенням або нулем, або
одиницею, що означає — на одному боці розрізу або на іншому. Ми можемо записати функцію як
пару вузлів x_i та x_j, яка вказує, чи відповідне ребро перебуває в розрізі. Таким чином, вираз x_i + x_j
мінус x_i * x_j визначає, чи ребро перебуває в розрізі. Якщо цей вираз дорівнює
одиниці, це означає, що ребро в розрізі, інакше він дорівнює нулю і ребро не перерізане. Задачу пошуку
максимальної кількості ребер у розрізі можна тоді сформулювати як максимізацію цієї функції. Далі ми насправді
додамо глобальний знак мінус до цієї функції, зробивши нову задачу еквівалентною знаходженню мінімуму цієї функції
натомість, і тому мінімум f(x) у цьому випадку буде тоді, коли кількість ребер, перетнутих розрізом, є
максимальною. Ми обираємо формулювання цієї задачі як задачі мінімізації, тому що це дозволяє нам пізніше звести її до задачі
мінімізації енергії, тобто пошуку основного стану, у чому квантові комп'ютери природно дуже сильні.
Але пам'ятай: тут ще немає нічого пов'язаного з квантовими обчисленнями. Нам ще потрібно переформулювати цю задачу в
щось, що квантовий комп'ютер може зрозуміти. Тепер ми готові глибоко зануритися і розпочати роботу,
і перший крок — відобразити задачу на квантовий circuit. Може бути неочевидним, як ми
перейдемо від графа, який щойно намалювали, до квантового circuit, але давай робитимемо це поступово. Пам'ятай: ми
намагатимемося розв'язати цю задачу Max cut за допомогою qaoa. В алгоритмі qaoa ми, зрештою, хочемо мати оператор —
гамільтоніан, який буде використовуватися для представлення функції вартості нашої задачі, а також параметризований
circuit — ansatz або пробний стан, який ми будемо використовувати для представлення квантових станів, що є освіченими здогадками або кандидатами
на розв'язок задачі. Ми можемо робити вибірку з цих станів-кандидатів, а потім оцінювати їх
за допомогою функції вартості — у цьому випадку функції вартості f(x). Але нам потрібно виразити її так,
щоб це було природним для квантового комп'ютера. Для цього ми скористаємося серією математичних
перетворень, щоб виразити f(x) як функцію енергії — гамільтоніан. Перший крок цього
процесу — виразити задачу мінімізації f(x) як задачу квадратичної безобмежувальної бінарної оптимізації,
або скорочено QUBO. QUBO — це загальний спосіб формулювання цих задач комбінаторної оптимізації.
Тут Q — матриця реальних чисел розміром N×N, N відповідає кількості
вузлів у нашому графі — п'ять для цього прикладу, а X — той самий вектор бінарних змінних із початкової
формулювання. Щоб ефективно запустити алгоритм qaoa, нам потрібно виразити нашу задачу оптимізації в термінах
гамільтоніана — математичного оператора, який представляє повну енергію системи. Зокрема, ми хочемо
створити гамільтоніан функції вартості, який має властивість, що його енергія основного стану або мінімальне власне значення
відповідає мінімуму функції, яка кодує максимальну кількість розрізів на графі G. Як тільки ми
маємо цей гамільтоніан, все, що нам потрібно для розв'язання нашої задачі оптимізації — це підготувати основний стан гамільтоніана на квантовому комп'ютері, а потім
вибірка з цього стану з великою ймовірністю дасть розв'язок мінімізації f(x). Як з'ясовується,
нам везе: задача QUBO дуже тісно пов'язана і насправді обчислювально еквівалентна
одному з найвідоміших і найпоширеніших гамільтоніанів у фізиці — гамільтоніану Ізінга. Щоб записати задачу QUBO
як цей гамільтоніан Ізінга, нам насправді потрібно лише просте перетворення змінних — перейти від
булевих змінних 0 і 1 до спінових змінних мінус один і один. Цей крок
простий: він детально показаний у додатку прикріпленого notebook для тих, кого це цікавить. Але в підсумку мінімізація цього виразу QUBO
є тією самою, що й мінімізація цього виразу. Перепишемо ще трохи,
і ми отримаємо наш гамільтоніан функції вартості, де мінімум виразу представляє основний стан, а Z
стає оператором Паулі, тоді як B — дійсний скалярний коефіцієнт. Тепер, маючи наш гамільтоніан,
його легко переписати в термінах двох локальних операторів ZZ Паулі, які легко перетворяться на
два gate ZZ у нашому квантовому circuit. Будь ласка, зверни увагу на пов'язаний notebook, щоб побачити, як це зробити. Але результат
наведено тут у цьому рядку. Зауваж, що в нашому прикладі є
шість об'єктів або рядків Паулі, оскільки кожен представляє ребро в графі. Довжина рядка відповідає кількості
вузлів, тому IIIZZ означає п'ять вузлів, і рядок складатиметься з
одиниць у всіх позиціях, крім індексів вузлів, що беруть участь у ребрі, які матимуть члени Z. В Qiskit
бітові рядки, що представляють qubit, індексуються у зворотному порядку. Наприклад, ребро між вузлами 0 і 1 буде закодовано як
IIIZZ. Маючи гамільтоніан, записаний у термінах операторів Паулі, ми готові побудувати наш
квантовий circuit. Цей квантовий circuit допоможе нам отримувати хороші розв'язки з квантового комп'ютера. Алгоритм qaoa
натхненний адіабатичною теоремою, яка стверджує, що якщо ми починаємо в основному стані залежного від часу
гамільтоніана і якщо гамільтоніан еволюціонує досить повільно і має достатньо часу, то кінцевий стан буде основним
станом кінцевого гамільтоніана. qaoa можна розглядати як дискретну версію Троттера квантового
адіабатичного алгоритму, де кожен крок Троттера представляє шар, який ми будемо називати P.
Отже, замість того щоб переходити від одного стану до іншого, у кожному шарі P ми будемо перемикатися між нашим гамільтоніаном функції вартості
і тим, що називається нашим гамільтоніаном-мікшером, про який ми дізнаємося більше трохи пізніше. Але суть, яку я хочу донести,
полягає в тому, що qaoa має перевагу бути швидшим за квантовий адіабатичний алгоритм, але він повертає наближені
розв'язки, а не оптимальні. У межі, де кількість шарів прямує до нескінченності, qaoa збігається до адіабатичного
випадку, але звичайно це обчислювально дуже дороговартісно. Для створення нашого квантового circuit
ми застосуємо почергові оператори, параметризовані тут gamma та beta,
які представляють дискретизацію часової еволюції. Отже, знову три основні частини
circuit qaoa: перша — початковий пробний стан у сірому, що є основним
станом мікшера з адіабатичного стану еволюції, створеним застосуванням gate Hadamard до кожного qubit. Друга —
еволюція функції вартості, яку ми вже маємо темно-фіолетовим кольором. Третя — еволюція за гамільтоніаном-мікшером,
який ми ще не обговорювали, показаний світло-фіолетовим. Наш початковий гамільтоніан називається
мікшером, тому що його основний стан є суперпозицією всіх можливих бітових рядків, що нас цікавлять, і, таким чином,
забезпечує поєднання всіх можливих розв'язків на початку. Гамільтоніан-мікшер — це проста сума операцій Паулі X
на кожному вузлі графа. Qiskit дозволяє тобі використовувати інший власний оператор-мікшер за бажанням, але
в цьому випадку ми просто використаємо стандартний. Знову ж таки, ти можеш бачити, що з Qiskit велика частина роботи
виконується за нас, що робить побудову гамільтоніана-мікшера та початкового стану тривіальним завданням. Єдина робота, яку нам довелося зробити, —
це знайти функцію вартості. Кожна ітерація цих операторів називається шаром. Ці шари можна розглядати як
дискретизації часової еволюції системи, як було описано раніше. Почерговий патерн виникає з
розкладу Троттера і апроксимує показникові функції некомутуючих матриць. Загалом, чим більше шарів або
кроків ми включаємо, тим ближчими ми будемо до неперервної часової еволюції, тому в теорії результат буде точнішим.
Але для цього прикладу ми почнемо просто з вибірки з двома шарами. Пам'ятай: і гамільтоніан функції вартості, і
мікшер параметризовані — нам ще потрібно знайти оптимальні значення для gamma та
beta. Я розумію, що це була велика кількість інформації, і якщо ти вперше бачиш такий тип математики, це може бути складно. На щастя, одна з чудових
речей у Qiskit полягає в тому, що велику частину того, що ми щойно розглянули, можна виконати автоматично без великих зусиль від користувача. Корисно розуміти, що відбувається
під капотом, особливо коли ми масштабуємося до більших експериментів, але тобі не доведеться виконувати всю цю роботу
вручну щоразу. Ми тепер відобразили нашу задачу на квантовий circuit. Це була певна робота,
але не хвилюйся — це стає легшим і більш інтуїтивним, чим більше ти це робиш. Тепер ми готові перейти до кроку два:
оптимізації нашого circuit для заліза. Отже, хоча circuit, який ми щойно створили, виглядає досить просто і
корисний для формування інтуїтивного розуміння, пам'ятай: квантовий чіп не розуміє, що таке цей абстрагований
блок. Нам потрібно перетворити його на серію однокубітних і двокубітних gate, які є нативними для заліза. Коли я
кажу «нативні», я маю на увазі, що він буде перероблений у те, що можна безпосередньо виконати на qubit. Такі circuit
вважаються написаними в архітектурі набору інструкцій backend, яку ти можеш зустріти в скороченні ISA circuit.
Модуль transpiler SDK Qiskit пропонує серію проходів транспіляції, які можуть
виконувати широкий спектр перетворень circuit. Ми хочемо переконатися, що наш circuit оптимізований для нашої
мети. Згадай із нашого попереднього уроку, що процес транспіляції включає кілька кроків: відображення
qubit у circuit або змінних рішень на фізичні qubit на пристрої, розгортання інструкцій у
квантовому circuit до нативних для заліза інструкцій, які backend насправді розуміє, маршрутизація будь-яких
qubit у circuit, які безпосередньо взаємодіють, до фізичних qubit, що є сусідніми один
з одним. І, як завжди, більше деталей про це можна знайти в документації.
Тепер настає захоплюючий крок: ми оберемо, на якому backend запустити наш circuit. Насправді це потрібно зробити
перед кроком транспіляції, тому що transpiler по-різному оптимізує для різних процесорів. Це ще одна причина, чому
важливо, що Qiskit може автоматизувати стільки цього етапу. Ти б не хотів оптимізувати свій circuit вручну —
це можна зробити, але іноді це складно і дуже витратно за часом, — тільки щоб потім зрозуміти, що хочеш запустити
свій circuit на іншому процесорі з іншими властивостями, і тоді тобі доведеться робити всю ту роботу знову. Передай
обраний тобою backend через функцію transpiler і не забудь вказати рівень оптимізації. Цього
разу я вибрав рівень оптимізації три, який є найвищим і найвичерпнішим рівнем оптимізації.
І це, власне, все для кроку два: мій circuit був автоматично транспільований, і я намалював його тут, щоб
ти міг побачити, як він був перекладений у однокубітні та двокубітні gate. Тепер час для кроку три:
запуску circuit з примітивами Qiskit. Досі ми транспілювали circuit, залишаючи параметри gamma та
beta незмінними, але ми насправді не можемо запустити circuit, не вказавши значення цих параметрів. У робочому процесі qaoa
оптимальні параметри qaoa знаходяться в ітеративному циклі оптимізації, де ми запускаємо серію оцінювань circuit
і використовуємо класичний оптимізатор для знаходження оптимальних параметрів beta та gamma. Однак нам потрібно з чогось почати,
тому я реалізував деякі початкові здогадки для gamma 1, gamma 2 та beta 1, beta 2 рівними Pi / 2 та Pi
відповідно. Також хочу, щоб ти зауважив, що ми будемо використовувати оптимізатор для пошуку кращих розв'язків для gamma та beta.
Оскільки я зараз обчислюю лише два шари, це все, що мені потрібно. Але якщо ти створиш точніший circuit qaoa,
ти включиш більше шарів і, отже, потребуватимеш оптимізованих gamma та beta для кожного послідовного
шару. Тепер давай на хвилину зупинимося і згадаємо наші варіанти примітивів: у нас є estimator і
sampler. Який, на твою думку, ми будемо використовувати для цього типу роботи? Що ж, незалежно від того, який ти вибрав,
ти насправді правий — ми збираємося використовувати і estimator, і sampler. Для початкового циклу оптимізації
нам знадобиться estimator, але ми будемо використовувати sampler пізніше для зчитування кінцевого
розв'язку. Тепер ми майже готові запустити наш алгоритм — обіцяю. Але дуже швидко важливо зазначити, що ти можеш
надсилати свою роботу різними способами, які називаються режимами виконання. Перший — режим job: одиничний
запит до примітива estimator або sampler, зроблений без context manager. Circuit та вхідні дані упаковуються як примітивні
уніфіковані блоки (PUB) і надсилаються як завдання виконання на квантовий
комп'ютер. Режим batch — це менеджер для ефективного запуску експерименту, що складається з набору
незалежних робіт. Використовуй режим batch для одночасного надсилання кількох примітивних робіт. Режим session — виділене
вікно для запуску багатозадачного навантаження. Це дозволяє преміум-користувачам експериментувати з варіаційними алгоритмами більш
передбачуваним способом і навіть запускати кілька експериментів одночасно, використовуючи паралелізм
стеку. Використовуй session для ітеративних робочих процесів та експериментів, що вимагають виділеного доступу. Для експерименту qaoa
session був би хорошим вибором, якщо у тебе є доступ до нього, оскільки тобі потрібно буде пробувати кілька circuit для різних значень beta
та gamma. Гаразд, повернімося до нашої задачі оптимізації. Ми вже
визначили гамільтоніан функції вартості HC, і повний робочий процес такий: алгоритм qaoa
починається з ініціалізації qubit у стані суперпозиції, потім застосовує ansatz із P шарами. Він
ініціалізує параметри gamma та beta, а потім запускає circuit за допомогою примітива estimator. Як тільки ми обчислимо
значення очікування, ми будемо використовувати оптимізатор scipy під назвою COBYLA. COBYLA
класично оптимізує функцію вартості поза QPU. Як тільки ці значення gamma та beta будуть оновлені, ми
повторюємо. Ми будемо робити це, доки значення загальної функції вартості не зійдеться і не досягне найнижчого значення.
Потім ми виберемо значення gamma та beta, що відповідають цьому низькому значенню вартості, і запустимо circuit востаннє.
Тепер використовуємо sampler. Це результат мого запуску оптимізатора COBYLA з моїми початковими здогадками. Тут ти можеш бачити,
що значення функції вартості по ітераціях спочатку трохи скаче вгору та вниз,
але потім стабілізується на низькому значенні. Ми будемо використовувати ці останні значення gamma та beta, що відповідають мінімальному значенню
функції вартості, щоб запустити circuit востаннє і зробити вибірку бітового рядка, який дасть нам Max
cut. Тепер, використовуючи наші оптимізовані значення для gamma та beta, ми запустимо circuit востаннє, щоб знайти найкращий
можливий бітовий рядок за допомогою sampler. Я перелічив конкретні значення, які використовую тут, але пам'ятай: коли ти
спробуєш це сам або навіть просто перезапустиш той самий навчальний notebook, ці значення можуть трохи змінитися. Тепер ми запустимо
наш оптимізований circuit із цими значеннями і знайдемо наш розв'язок-кандидат для нашої задачі Max cut. Якщо ти використовував
session — це більше не потрібно, оскільки ми запускаємо лише одну останню роботу. Тепер ми нарешті подивимося на
етап постобробки та знаходження нашого кінцевого розв'язку. Спочатку побудуємо графік усіх
можливих комбінацій вузлів, які ми перетворили на бітові рядки, у вигляді гістограми. Ти відразу бачиш, що
коли я запустив це, я знайшов чотири розв'язки і виділив їх фіолетовим — вони більш ймовірні, ніж будь-який інший розв'язок.
Найвищий і, отже, найбільш ймовірний бітовий рядок — 01010. Зауваж порядок qubit:
на графіку він зворотний. Дивлячись на найбільш ймовірний розв'язок, зауважимо, що вузли 0 і три згруповані разом,
і аналогічно для вузлів 1, 2 та чотири. Ми нарешті можемо побудувати найбільш ймовірний
бітовий рядок назад як граф. Пам'ятай: бітовий рядок просто відповідає номерам вузлів і тому, чи вони включені —
позначені одиницею — або не включені — позначені нулем — у нашу групу. Коли ми малюємо розріз, ми можемо бачити на очі
наближену лінію для найкращого розрізу, яка просто представляє ідеальне групування всіх п'яти вузлів — я намалював її тут. Одна
річ, якій я хочу приділити час тут, — це те, що правильний розв'язок не є унікальним.
Через симетрію цього графа є кілька правильних розв'язків. Замість вузлів 0 і три всередині розрізу,
ми могли б мати вузли 2 та чотири включеними, і ти можеш бачити, що все, що мені потрібно було зробити, — це повернути мій розріз, щоб
включити ці нові точки. Цей розв'язок із п'ятьма залишається незмінним.
Давай ще раз поглянемо на гістограму та чотири найбільш ймовірні розв'язки на хвилину. Два останні розв'язки —
ті, які ми щойно побудували, і вони однаково правильні. Але це ще не все: ми також могли б інвертувати кольори для всіх
правильних розв'язків, і цього разу ми просто думаємо про вузли як про ті, що знаходяться всередині проти зовні розрізу. На
попередньому слайді ми визначили два унікальних правильних розв'язки, але насправді є ще два розв'язки: один відповідає
протилежному до кожного з тих. Подивись: тут, де я намалював два розв'язки, що залишилися, я просто інвертував
кольори. Тепер єдина проблема полягає в тому, що алгоритм насправді не знайшов і не ідентифікував цей четвертий останній розв'язок як
один із чотирьох найбільш ймовірних відповідей. Він був п'ятим. Четвертий розв'язок, який ідентифікував алгоритм,
насправді неправильний, і якщо б ти намалював його, ти побачив би, що цей розв'язок має лише чотири розрізи. Оскільки інші
мають п'ять, а чотири явно менше за п'ять, це, очевидно, неправильно. Суть тут полягає в тому,
що це наближений алгоритм. Він не є непогрішним і не є правильним 100% часу. Тобі потрібно
застосувати власні знання та розуміння, щоб перевірити розв'язки на адекватність. Варто підкреслити, що
ця помилка може виникати з кількох місць: вона може бути наближеною природою самого алгоритму і малою
кількістю шарів, які я вибрав. Це може бути скінченна похибка вибірки, яку можна зменшити, якщо збільшити
кількість shots в моєму експерименті. Або це може бути помилка зчитування, оскільки четвертий реальний розв'язок відрізняється лише на один
біт. Причина, чому я вказую на всі ці можливості, полягає в тому, що це те, що потрібно, щоб стати справжнім
практиком квантових обчислень. Тобі потрібно розуміти продуктивність заліза і те, як це може сприяти
певним типам помилок і як їх виправляти. Однак не забуваймо, що
існувало 32 можливих бітових рядки і що чотири реальних розв'язки були включені в топ-п'ять
найкращих кандидатів, і я використовував лише два шари для цього. Загалом, якщо я хочу збільшити свої шанси знайти
найкращий Max cut щоразу, я б збільшив глибину шарів. Тут є певні тонкощі, але це для пізнішого
епізоду. Тепер я збираюся дозволити тобі спробувати це самостійно, але цього разу ти будеш використовувати 100
qubit. Отже, якщо ми почнемо з побудови нашого графа з 100 qubit, ти бачиш, що вже не є очевидним або навіть можливим
на погляд визначити, де відбувається Max cut. Є просто надто багато можливостей, щоб вибрати її вручну. Але
розв'язання цієї задачі за допомогою qaoa все ще цілком здійсненно, і ти можеш дотримуватися того самого робочого процесу, який ми використовували для 5
qubit. Я збираюся відправити тебе самостійно і доручити тобі спробувати провести цей експеримент, але перш ніж зробити це,
підсумуймо. Згадай, що шість кроків будь-якої роботи qaoa такі: перший — визначення
гамільтоніана вартості таким чином, що його основний стан кодує розв'язок задачі оптимізації; другий — визначення
гамільтоніана-мікшера; третій — побудова операторів, що відповідають експоненціалізованим
гамільтоніанам; четвертий — побудова circuit: він складатиметься з початкового основного стану мікшера та почергових
повторюваних шарів функції вартості та еволюції під гамільтоніаном-мікшером; п'ятий — підготовка початкового стану і
використання класичних обчислювальних технік для оптимізації параметрів; шостий — запуск circuit, вимірювання вихідних бітових рядків,
пошук найбільш ймовірного розв'язку. Тепер кілька речей, які варто відзначити: я
використовував рівень оптимізації три для мого прикладу з 5 qubit, але, можливо, це не було необхідним, і правильна відповідь могла б
все ще повертатися більшість часу на нижчому рівні оптимізації, оскільки глибина circuit була досить низькою для випадку з 5
qubit. Але для 100 qubit і великої глибини circuit ти майже напевно потребуватимеш найвищого рівня
оптимізації, щоб знайти правильну відповідь. Також майте на увазі, що одна з найскладніших частин типового utility
scale робочого процесу — це етап відображення та пошук графа, який добре відповідає топології IBM heavy hex. Якщо б ти
виконував цю роботу з нуля, саме тут ти б, безперечно, витрачав більшу частину свого часу. Зараз ця частина була
зроблена за тебе, оскільки це не головна мета цієї вправи. Але майте на увазі, що це те, що ми будемо
вимагати практикувати. Запуск великомасштабної роботи не завжди є простим — ми детальніше розглянемо це
в епізоді 4. Твій кінцевий circuit, очевидно, виглядатиме набагато заплутаніше, ніж circuit, що запускався на 5 qubit,
але, з іншого боку, мені здається, що дивитися на цей circuit і бачити, скільки gate він має, і знаючи, що ти
маєш можливість насправді запустити це на реальних квантових процесорах — це досить
вражає. І це був мій кінцевий розв'язок. Ти можеш бачити, що алгоритм, безумовно, здатний групувати ці
вузли на дві групи, нібито ідентифікуючи найкращий Max cut, що ділить їх, переходячи від двох наборів
до лінії Max cut — це тривіально: будь-де, де колір змінюється вздовж ліній, що з'єднують вузли, позначає,
де слід провести лінію Max cut. Коли я запустив це, максимальне значення розрізу, якого мені вдалося досягти, —
84. Тож спробуй сам і дай знати в коментарях, чи отримуєш щось схоже. Спробуй три шари, може чотири, спробуй
змінити ваги між вузлами і подивися, як це змінює результат. Є дуже багато цікавих експериментів,
які ми можемо провести з qaoa. Пам'ятай: не гарантовано, що я щойно знайшов найкращий можливий
розв'язок. Ми знаємо, що це хороший розв'язок, але для розваги кидаю тобі виклик — спробуй перемогти мене: подивися, чи зможеш ти отримати щось
краще за 84. На завершення: qaoa — це дуже динамічний
алгоритм, і є дуже багато евристик і ще багато чого для вивчення. Він дає багато можливостей для вивчення нових
речей у галузі оптимізації загалом. Останнім часом у просторі оптимізації було дуже багато роботи —
про це свідчать усі статті на arXiv, які нещодавно були опубліковані онлайн про qaoa або оптимізацію. І що
справді круто — нарешті не всі ці статті є теоретичними. Теоретики вивчали
qaoa роками, але тепер до роботи долучаються експериментатори, тому що ми нарешті маємо залізо —
наприклад, процесори IBM — здатне запускати багато з цих експериментів. Ми переходимо з уявного простору
в реальний світ, і це дуже захоплює. Так, ще багато роботи попереду і ще
чимало помилок, з якими нам потрібно навчитися справлятися, але ми швидко прогресуємо. І ти, переглядаючи це
відео, якщо дійшов так далеко, — здатний запускати ці експерименти самостійно. Будь ласка, іди і спробуй запустити свій власний
експеримент зі 100 qubit і дай нам знати, як все пройшло. Слідуй навчальному матеріалу — і будеш у надійних руках. Якщо ти
маєш якісь запитання або зайшов у глухий кут — не хвилюйся: ми всі так відчували або мали ті самі запитання, коли тільки починали
це вивчати. Роби все можливе, дай нам знати, які питання виникають, і до зустрічі наступного разу.
[Музика]